so I'm going to be starting you off here
with some of the latest and greatest
tools that we have so I'm going to take
you on a bit of a journey here bear with
me this is going to be fast and furious
and I'm going to be throwing a lot of
information at you and a lot of it's
gonna be quite high-level the idea here
is to kind of get this on your radar if
you've not heard of these tools yet some
of them maybe you're already using and
we'll be talking a little bit about best
practices as well but essentially
envision this being a buffet I'm gonna
set up a variety of dishes and tasty
treats some of it you might like some of
it you might not like and it's
completely up to you as to what you
think will benefit you and your team to
make the best game you possibly can so
here you'll see we're gonna be talking
about pre-launch launch window and post
launch
so first we'll dive into pre-launch and
this is where I'm going to be spending
quite a bit of time because really
here's where you are going to be forging
in the fire to create your best game
right this is where you're going to be
doing a lot of testing you're going to
be iterating a lot making a lot of
mistakes learning from it so here's the
opening mantra that I wanted to throw at
you which is test earlier test wider
test better so maybe the first and the
third feel comfortable for you as a
small team maybe the middle one not so
much so this is something that we've
been advocating for for teams of all
kinds of sizes because we've built a lot
of tools that allow you to do this and
there's a benefit to test wider which
hopefully means you're doing a lot of
problem-solving and eliminating
eliminating those unforeseen issues that
pop up once you have launched and
perhaps you didn't test as widely as you
you did so first let us start with
internal testing this is a really great
way and a great tool to use for your
team this is team testing this allows
you to launch a new build within seconds
versus hours very fast iteration you're
getting you're getting different builds
out several times a day if needed if
you're doing quick fixes and you're
really addressing that foundational
stuff early on next we move to close
testing this is where you broaden out a
little bit to maybe your your highest
engaged users those who are really
excited about your game may be friends
and family as well and here's where you
can start getting a sense of what your
your gamers are telling you this is this
is very foundational feedback that
you're getting initially from a very
small set of your user base this is also
known as closed beta so here we have our
friends that butterscotch shenanigans
talking about their experience and
essentially this has been crucial for
them in targeting those bugs and those
crashes so that they're launching a
product that they feel confident about
they feel good about it and the tool
really facilitates that for them what
this also does for you is it allows you
to start getting a little bit more of
that wider testing in their wider
variety of users so you're getting a
spectrum of feedback close testing also
is great because it gives you a chance
to not have any kind of ratings effects
okay so if you're wanting to take big
bold moves around feature testing you
want to you one of your your team
members has a crazy idea and you want to
throw it out there into the wild within
this particular audience this is a great
place to do that
so who's sort of early access has anyone
been part of the early access program
play great okay so this is our official
program this is a program that you
actually have to apply for and this is
open beta that is officialized as a
program on play and the difference
between open beta which I'll be speaking
to right after this which anyone can do
you don't have to apply for is that this
gives you an opportunity to actually be
featured on the store and the next slide
will also talk about what that
collection looks like so when you
actually apply for this and if you get
accepted you are then merchandised on
the store as an unreleased game so this
is a great way to get visibility and
start funneling users for free into your
game really great for Indies I know a
lot of Indies just don't have you a
budget or it's very minimal or you have
to be very strategic about where you use
that and this is an opportunity to give
you that leg up and get that visibility
the important caveat around this program
is that your apk cannot have been in
production at all in any country if you
want to actually be a part of early
access so they're always experimenting
to see how they can get as many gamers
into your game as possible but at the
end of the day you're getting really
great visibility around that and so
here's our Iron Horse who we have with
us today who was talking about how
instrumental this has been to launching
their games especially in that that beta
phase and getting users into their games
early and how incredibly useful that's
been for them and Mike will actually be
speaking on a panel a little bit later
today
and he'll I'm sure this topic will come
up as well and feel free to ask him
questions about that and so this is open
beta so if let's say you spend some time
in early access you got some really
great visibility you're not quite ready
to fully launch yet this is an
opportunity to then move over into
that next phase of open beta and again
this is where you can have a lot of
freedom to still be doing testing to get
a sense of what's working and what isn't
and not have any consequences of ratings
so the thing about Google Play is that
if you have a rating at this stage in
the game it does stick with your overall
average rating so it's really important
to iterate as much as you can before
full launch when the ratings really do
start mattering and this gives you an
opportunity to make those mistakes and
not have those consequences show up on
your user rating okay so to sum it all
up here are all of those phases I
mentioned you start off very fast very
iterative with your own team working out
the fundamentals then you can broaden it
out a little bit close testing with a
very small group of your user base get
some really good detailed feedback then
you can move into early access if you
wish start getting some visibility
around your game in that unreleased
phase and then lastly you can transition
into open beta or open testing and
really broaden it out as wide as you can
before you go into full launch so one
little thought starter that I'd like to
plant in your mind is continuously
evaluate your process teams of all sizes
this is not just an indie thing we've
seen large teams get stuck in ruts
around how they develop games and I
think it's really easy to get into a
pattern and get into a habit and it
becomes solidified as we all know mobile
is still moving stupid fast there's a
lot of change there's a lot of
volatility in this market and Android
Google is always launching new tools for
you so always look at how you can
optimize your own process because at the
end of the day this is your opportunity
to make the best game you can and I I
want you to be successful and play wants
you to be successful okay so now we're
in launch window so here's a couple
things
be touching on quickly that will give
you some thought starters and things to
check out maybe I'd say one or two
months before you're launched so maybe
we can make you a hundred percent
confident maybe not a hundred percent
maybe way more confident than you have
been in the past I remember what that
was like to launch games and how
nerve-wracking that was and watching
user ratings and watching the stats on
the from the play console or from the
back end of whatever platform you've
launched on so hopefully we can minimize
those stress points here we are device
catalog and pre-registration so anyone
used the device catalog raise your hands
a couple oh great this is an opportunity
for you all this is exciting
okay so one of the great things about
Android is that you can reach a lot of
users we have a huge variety of devices
out there that read the reach is
incredible now we all know the downside
of that fragmentation can be a bit of a
nightmare especially when you are a very
small team it's it's very intimidating
and it's quite unruly so I encourage you
all to check out the device catalog
because what this is is knowledge for
you and knowledge is power and
essentially what the device catalog is
is within the play console this is
something each and every one of you can
access from your own play console is you
can see a list of thousands of devices
Android devices with a ton of really
great dent granular detail and I'll show
you an example of what that screen looks
like and this is here because we want to
really reduce those pain points of the
fragmentation of the ecosystem but also
to I would challenge you all to try to
support as many devices as you can one
thing that I hear this fairly common
across Indies is that there's this
really great desire to want to get your
game into as many players hands which I
think is a really beautiful thing to
achieve and I would hate to see you
limited by that by devices and of course
that's going to depend on the game right
there's certain games that you just
can't run on certain devices so start
wide start as broad as you can which
will feel very scary and
counterintuitive but really what you're
able to do then is once you launch or
once you have your your game running on
as many devices as you can you can then
go into the detail pages right here and
you can see things like RAM screen size
density all sorts of really great
details around the specs of those
devices and icing on top of that is you
can see actually how your game is doing
from a sales perspective on those
devices and it's interesting to hear how
many developers that are using the
device catalog are very surprised by how
there's some segments or grouping of
devices that they just weren't aware of
or had no idea that their game was
performing quite well and that there was
an opportunity for them to optimize and
make that experience better so this is
your chance to not only serve as many
gamers as you possibly can in the rich
ecosystem that is Android it also gives
you the power to provide a consistent
and fun experience no matter which
device they're on
so just to recap a little bit about that
try to support as many devices you can
use that knowledge empower yourself with
everything the device catalog is giving
you and then really laser cut out those
devices that that that information is
telling you is not working and try to do
it temporarily some you may not ever be
able to support but there may be some
that you
just had written off that you could
revisit and address later on so again
you're broadening your user base next
pre-registration pre-registration is an
opportunity for you to build hype this
is you getting a page up on the store
that allows gamers to a know that your
game is coming before you're even
launched gives them a little bit of
information about what your game is
about and allows them to click on the
sign up now button and they will then
get a notification when your game
launches it's a great way to see and
anticipate interest so that you can have
an understanding of how if you were in
tandem in in closed beta or open beta it
gives you an opportunity to understand
how to maybe manage your UA or your
community of building efforts it's a
very useful tool that way and here's
some best practices that we recommend in
terms of time frames so anywhere from
three to eight weeks I actually think
the sweet spot is about a month and give
yourself a chance to plan for this so
pre-registration I'm going to be
speaking a little bit more on this in a
second
this is actually not available to
everyone yet and I have a caveat for
that just for everyone here in the room
today but this is something you do
actually have to apply for much like
early access it's a program it's a very
specific program that you have to you
have to submit a request for
so as I just alluded to and kind of
teased on you will be receiving some
information after this event via email
about those of you who who have not been
part of the Early Access program around
this you will actually be able to apply
for pre-registration before we fully
fully launch it by the end of the year
so keep your eye out for that this is a
really cool tool and opportunity for you
to be a part of something before we
launch it to the community at large
okay now let's head into post launch so
we'll be talking about a couple things
here we're going to be talking about an
insights page which is actually quite
new as a feature and very useful as well
as play instant and then I'll touch very
lightly on vitals is actually something
Ben is going to talk a little bit more
about later okay so where are your
players coming from this is a question
that we would or a feature that we would
get requested on the regular by
developers big and small which is can
you please give us visibility into how
people are finding us on the store here
you go this is how you can check that
out this breaks it down in terms of
search terms gives you a sense of how
people are finding their way to your
game on the Play Store very useful tool
here's one of our developers saying that
it's just been an incredible insight for
them and has really allowed them to
figure out how to optimize their pay
their description pages and how to
leverage search words as best as
possible to the advantage of gamers be
able to find their game on the Play
Store so then how can you actually get
more users into your game we have Play
instant this is a piece of technology
that we've optimized for games
specifically just recently and this
gives gamers an opportunity to play a
small segment of your game without
downloading anything ostensibly what it
does is it puts a try Now button on
there once you've implemented that API
and this is a really great way to break
down that friction right especially if
you make paid games highly recommend
this here's some information around what
kind of conversion rates we're seeing
around user acquisition for indie games
specifically this is early days we just
have gamer game developers starting to
implement this in the past few months so
we're seeing anywhere from eight percent
to twenty percent you a uplift and
here's a bunch of ways that you can
actually funnel people into your instant
games so we have it implemented into ads
we have deep links there's a place on
the store this a collection that's
dedicated to this a lot of really great
ways to leverage this highly recommend
it here's some more information for you
around instant games give you guys a
chance to take a picture okay all right
vitals vitals is something that will
give you a snapshot into the health of
your game crash rates wakelocks things
like that we want to be able to give you
that very quick picture into how your
game is performing and how users are
experienced in your game and where you
can actually troubleshoot so subway
surfers who's wildly popular game on
play they have been using it and just
recently they were able to address a
crash that was coming out of nowhere and
allowed them to fix that really quickly
definitely take a look at that okay
so there's the buffet for you that's
everything we quickly went through so
some final thoughts I know that was a
lot I know that was kind of information
overload but I would invite you to
really pick and choose what's going to
work for your team not everything will
apply
and that's okay it's really your choice
into what you would like to use but
don't be afraid of change and don't be
afraid to try something new I know that
the console can be quite overwhelming
because we have so many great tools and
it's a lot give it a try and here are
some more resources for you for that
really quick high touch that I just gave
you here's where you can do deep dive
into those features there's a lot to
learn there's a bunch that I didn't even
mention so here are your resources and
here's where you can get updates thanks
everyone
appreciate that
[Applause]